this is the terror within and as that I
think they're implying Nickelodeon yes I
was gonna say is that what you're saying
the last commercial they had before this
episode was you know it remember you
can't watch this episode online except
for all future episodes which you will
now be watching online should we talk at
all about that
I mean hey let's just go over this again
okay so some of the episodes get leaked
so Nickelodeon then decides screw its
whole marketing campaign screw
everything at ahead planned rush this
sucker out the door and then on top of
that let's throw two episodes at once in
what appears to be now a time slot of
death then rant and rave about how you
can't watch these episodes online and
then without any warning whatsoever it
seems like even the creators were caught
by surprise let's just suddenly say you
know what we give up now watch all of
the rest of the episodes online I was
gonna say so my question is did you guys
Nickelodeon come up with that yourselves
or do you have a whole team of monkeys
helping you out with that one guys it is
funny when even the creators have to go
on their Facebook or on top of where I
just say it's not a cancel it's not
yes'm sorry
Nickelodeon's run by complete idiots but
it's not canceled it's I mean from what
I understand there's obviously gonna
keep showing though the rest of season
there is a season four I believe well
they already greenlit it I think it's
not in production which maybe
Nickelodeon's way of saying oh crap I
guess we're dedicated by watch but it's
all gonna be online they're all gonna be
like stick figure so it's gonna end like
Evangelion the last episodes are all
done in cramp oh no it I I just don't
get it I know the creators don't want to
burn any bridges man you poor guys have
gone through enough I don't even know
where to start I know I've read some
things where they're just like whoa no
this is part of Nickelodeon's plan from
the beginning because they found out it
did really well online so they were
gonna put it online you know eventually
and doesn't and this is the wave of the
future but yeah here's the thing though
yeah that was their plan from the
beginning to just pick a random
arbitrary episode and just
and from now on online after we were
telling you you couldn't see it
yeah weird even more episodes leaked or
something like that is I I don't know
it's and it's the inmates are running
the asylum over there oh no it's like oh
good
why does it say what makes me laugh even
more is like I jumped about it on my
public Facebook I'm like what was
there's some very special episode of
Spongebob you guys are sitting on that
you wanted to unload on us instead you
have like a backlog of SpongeBob's it is
like we got to do something with this
book or online let's run those funds Bob
episodes cuz I'm not kidding you want to
know what came on right after this
recordings it was totally fucking sons
Bob Squarepants I'm like oh my god my
lame is joke predicted it so I don't
know what's going on there I can't add I
have no business mind so I have no idea
how this stuff works I came in
comprehend what stuff goes well um but
it happens every which way now that it
doesn't have the post avatar bump
hey well what was that one captain man
or whatever that was to me that looks
funny did that that was funny like we
had you watching the advertisement for
that life essentially kind of what's
cute though because like the way the
recording the the recording works here
with Comcast is it catches about the
last minute only this advertise so
there's there's this episode of like
it's every which way is that it
so like yes about witches I think it
doesn't make the punch cars am pun oh
yeah we were joking that they should
just come up with one called this shit
writes itself and it's it's about a pile
of shit with quirky friends yeah it
writes itself like that's pretty much
nickelodeon fiction like selfie the show
I can selfie the show be on television
yeah core is going online that's not a
collodion I know but some girl is blue
in the face like she's literally all
blue and then some other girl opens a
locker and she turns get squirts
squirted by a freeway we're going to
talk away too much about PC turns into a
parent okay and I just looked at Doug
and I'm like so we're losing avatar to
this sort of shit hey hey hey I'll spare
key okay get a ride you know I'm pretty
much how can I trust you if you get your
own prayer
pretty sure was a parent well and we saw
it Plus knowing the cows that's all it's
gonna be lame and that is a peracare
compares turkey good so any who would
you fried talk about the episode uh okay
this is the terror within should we give
a crap about the episode more
Nickelodeon does is that what you're
saying maybe I'm talking about um
there's an episode where it's uh uh core
is getting kidnapped in the opening by
the shit gets real yeah the the for
Expendables and pretty much they go and
at this pretty kick-ass fight really
there's like lava vending that's a thing
now you know I'm still trying I'm still
trying to get my head around combustion
bending and now we of lava banding I'm
like I think so is all I'm doing really
cool does that fall under earth bending
or fire bending I'm not sure uh yeah I
thought maybe they came together and
anything else
oh maybe oh that was my thought yeah cuz
it's like when it's earth it's fire um
what's really I guess it's not really
well maybe onyx release another women
maybe two of them came together yeah I
know but water would just cool it it was
cool uh so that that's really cool fight
goes on for a while and then they're
like they get quarterback and they're
like oh no let's use the move we should
use before to get out there and they get
out of there um and it was a really
awesome fight that's what kills me yeah
it was a really cool come out on TV on
this episode and I'm like that fight was
amazing well I get to watch on your
computer not that there's anything wrong
with that
not that we have no but you might not
get as big a be like the old days that I
was watching anime yeah it is kind of
like they're forcibly asking you to
pirate them now it's like legally
pirating I guess it's really okay okay
we're gonna sidetrack the problem is I
wouldn't do that cuz this is gonna stiff
the creators so oh yeah I bet I did not
want all the leaked episodes I am I am
no I didn't either cuz I'm like well
just wait for it but even if I did I'd
still watch it again and I don't think
it really matters anyway we're not
hooking a Nielsen rating system so uh so
they're so they they get away and
they're trying to find how do they know
how to get in and everything so they
think it's one of the guards and the
just
and just like you or just like me you
figured it out like almost in select
yeah well this guy who could figure out
if you're lying
that would be release yeah sure enough
it is it's a guy who can figure out that
your line who's lying uh so they figure
that out and they try to they trying to
stop in the heat gets away and soo
pretty much lies to Lin and says you go
I'm allowing you a way out go find them
catch him um love Joey hi to you this is
Cora find it I'm and it stops right
there
um which I'll sing it actually is weird
not having to up so it's also oh it's
over so I felt kind of gypped I'm just
like oh man isn't there more yeah I like
I really want more but uh I guess I'll
watch online now oh yeah so I mean I
mean it's really good I'm leaning more
towards soon as a part of it I don't
know um the fact that maybe the fact
that they could get out so easily why
would they do that unless she wants this
to go after odd unprotected yeah she had
this weird thing the animation was
interesting when they said uh it was it
was I way I wear the High Line is it was
it was I way all along he betrayed us
and like her eyes start left to right
like blue yeah it was like when you're
dealing with the animation like every
frame counts yeah so why would you go
that in there yeah why would they show
her eyes darting because they seriously
like darn it away for a second like huh
the fact you didn't want lid to know the
fact that she wants them these four and
then the core and the others away from
the city alone something's up and if she
is involved the question is is she
really a bad guy or is she part of some
other conspiracy going on well the other
thing I was thinking too is that the
resolution cuz we were saying play that
resolution with the sisters was over
pretty quick uh that would make sense
think I said they finally have closure
just to have it explode again one that
we can talk about conspiracy theories
again on avatar I feel like you know the
shows getting interesting and calming
about what we knew exactly who the
fill in one yeah it's like instantly
like Beckett yeah tar-like well I guess
in some ways we kind of did like this
time because they pretty blow showed you
pretty Gavin prints well okay yeah but
at the same time I don't know um I'm not
gonna lie I'm hoping his her just so I
can prove that my conspiracy was right
all the time I know it's her but I'm
hoping she's that evil like she's got
good intentions and she already had sort
of shaky pass to so or though their way
I could see it going is that maybe Lynn
has trouble trusting her again and she
says no I'm really not
a part of this this is not my thing I
swear it's a setup
I mean we really friend yeah that's
where what I'm wondering - so either of
those would be a good animal um it
definitely created more drama because
like well I like the thing the sisters I
was like that I was over pretty quick
but they go this direction that would
really they were give a reason for that
being really quick good bull in Episode
two I felt like he had a part to play
and yeah I thought this comedy works
pretty well this one actually I liked it
because team avatar got to play and save
the avatar
yeah which was a nice switch up like cuz
she just would I mean she tried she's
like imma kick your ass and then like
one dart is a put oh crap well first
season had a lot of and they took out my
manbearpig to like instantly like I was
like wow these guys came ready to go the
first things I remember a lot of times
like so what was swinging in catching
core or something like well yeah but I
missed a second this isn't even the like
she's just completely she was in a coma
the entire battle like so so that's hard
to say because on the one hand it's like
why didn't they do that move from the
beginning but on the other hand man
that's a pretty intense battle like it'd
be the throws all state it'd be a pretty
well staged battle if that was all fake
so I don't know so I don't know I like
it it's a nice happy conspiracy theories
because like I said Monday it was a fun
episode it was a really fun battle like
the third eye they seated in the
combustion combustion bender the way she
would just fling that around yeah and
try to outflank them and it was like
there was actual strategy involved in
this family
is fun this is more like the original
avatar one the pointing to a musket
attica no no no is a divot there's a
different kind of a where they have one
of the quote unquote benders if you use
one the martial arts they uh who taught
gonna go bending but it was a style
martial arts / talk for the earthbending
sweep
so like Bend that earth over there that
ended I think I crane a stamp
oh wait that tree moved oh that was the
wind no uh okay but yeah but what I
realize is that watching them as adults
and having seen like not like a frickin
class of people you know do these moves
and stuff uh you realize that or at
least I know in this I can feel the
weight of every move in it like whenever
they in every time it's like the moves
are incredible they're really good but
either cuz they were younger or maybe I
may show is a little different it
slightly it looked great and look
proportionate but it didn't quite feel
like the weight was always here I feel
like it's more like their I feel like
it's more anime this time around in the
style of animation even more so than the
original avatar and you're right and
that's something I like about anime is
it's sometimes as a lower frame rate but
you get that sense of power when you
move I think of things like Cowboy Bebop
and stuff where you might feel the
weight like a weight of the body when it
moves no it's completely true and it's
something that sometimes Western
animation lacks sometimes it get it
really well but um uh but yeah I mean a
might say it's good fight in the opening
that the rest is just sort of like a you
know and where's it going uh kind of
episode not a Todmorden but I would have
gotten away with it if it weren't for
your screwy dog so talk about bullet
that way um and I agree about bowling it
was nice seeing him like the Kombi was
good but he really had he really had
kind of a perky took the combustion
bender out like yeah and it wasn't
totally played for laughs so you can
really sort of felt like you know come
on you really wanted to succeed and
though they're jumping down and the
suspense is building you know he has
this one shot you kind of feel the
tension there I don't like to because
all of the stuff was piling up in this
episode have you seen this meme going
around where it's like opals leaving so
here's attacking I
metalbend that it cuts to spiderman the
cartoon is just like em proms tomorrow
good name who's been making around but
yeah kinda I was just bigger than that
as well I was watching the second time
here I'm like yeah they crammed a lot
the stuff that's kind of what I like
like I'm completely invested I'm into
the characters they cram a lot of stuff
in I is there been a boring episode I
don't think I've been bored yet I'll say
is it - every time sir I'll say this
about a like I said comparing this you
see because I do like this season a lot
more than season two but I will say
there was something about - thinking
back to it as a whole now this
individual episode that as a whole it
end the first one - but if it strangely
enough even more with - there was this
size to it it felt very big it felt like
there's this big thing going on it just
wasn't always told right I still win
everyone seems that it feels like it's a
smaller story but it's done better I
still feel the most complete narrative
with season 1 I didn't I really have a
problem ously someone I had an issue
with the ending that's the last 10 15
minutes of it but I thought all of
season one was the most tight narrative
I'm like okay they had a set story you
know and then Nickelodeon asked for more
seasons so they can you know shit all
over so they can put yeah TV so that
cannot put it on TV but like that caught
them by surprise so I feel like even as
good as this season is I still feel like
meandering a bit but season one I
thought was really the tightest but I've
enjoyed this season a lot so far uh yeah
like I said that there is a part of me
that wishes it's hard to say cuz the
second one likes it definitely flawed
and not always done well but it was so
huge I mean there's literally a giant
Godzilla Korra fighting a nother
Godzilla person there that was good bad
ya know know how this is gonna end up
but you also have like you know the the
world combining it I just met this giant
imagery in these big battles going on
with this one that was all at the end
but we haven't where are we at the
halfway point yeah yeah the spirits come
by Adam dresses
okay so we're past the halfway point
yeah I mean I may be I don't know we're
we're in very close to the I mean that
closely yeah by me well I think Nick
demanded that they be self-contained so
yeah I don't think this is gonna be like
a long to be continued thing wanted to
be self-contained that way if we want to
back out of this we totally can but yeah
we're just throw in on life at what is
wrong with you people
so um yeah no I that's like it's what it
is one of those things where it's like I
don't know cuz I know what on the one
hand it's like like don't do we always
want them getting bigger and bigger like
hey we're gonna put even more crap to a
point where it's like just uncomfortable
like they're trying to force themselves
there's like I just tell the story you
naturally want to tell and then I like
it's better than this one ya know I do I
had uh it's much more it's not as I but
it just it's flowing organically yeah
just tied to season one and it's not as
epic as season two but I just I just
like all the characters and this is
flowing and it's like I i saw guardians
of the galaxy already and that film is
very similar i feel like it's just he
his wife won a contest by yeah everybody
was like whoa dude it's showing what no
no she she won a contest so we got to
see like an advanced screening I really
liked it by the way it was pretty cool
oh now they don't need to see something
rivalry nice but why did you like it and
if you saw do you like to that was Craig
no like no no because maybe you're not
gonna like it
maybe I built it too much for you I
don't know how I could just like a movie
with a talking gun shooting record and a
tree voiced by Vin Diesel alright Bessy
that was kind of my thought but um
actually yeah so but it's the same thing
because I'm like it's not the most epic
story like that movie was it's not the
most epic story but I just really liked
those five sort of characters and the
story's not spectacular but just
watching these five characters interact
is a lot of fun and it's the same with
this season of Avatar it's like the
story sonometer I'm sorry well okay
Korra did
karna keep talking yeah it's the same
thing she she the show is really good
when it's just Dee
with these characters just doing their
thing it's just things are just sort of
happy naturally and it may not be the
most grand epic plot may not be tightly
written but there's a real like out the
word Furby charm to this season
yeah it like it's just fun yeah it seems
it does seem lighter but that's a little
welcoming too
um like I said as long as they got light
I think you guys long as the narrative
is very you know it's very continuous
and it's very flowing and the characters
are very likable it's kind of like sure
like you know why not it's still very
freedom look at some times maybe it's
just more enjoyable to watch a fun cute
small little story over something that's
like big epic it means something you
know that's what I took out of guardians
of the galaxy and it's kind of when I'm
taken out of this cuz you're right
season 2 I guess was like more epic in
this method I find this fun I'm actually
having more fun just watching these
episodes and their little side
adventures as they I'm almost wondering
I mean like when we talked about you
know Nickelodeon is like you know what
are the numbers down it's like they've
made a lot of mistakes here um I've run
over another time but no ever times up
above it that is something I'm wondering
though to is you know is sort of the
lack of the grand epic story scale
playing a part - and my guess would be
no my guess would be no because I'll bet
you a thousand dollars in because every
one I tell you know everyone's upset
that it's going to you know everyone's
upset to everybody everyone is you I can
do say they like yeah everyone I've
turned out there is there may be one
thing playing into this which is a
drop-off from people I know plenty
Bieber's like three Ventura fuck how
much I'm not even gonna bother you'll
never get me back
never and some of those people may have
left that may explain some of the
numbers being down but you know to them
I say your loss like this season I think
is a big improvement um but I don't work
for the Transformers so there's like
transformers two socks with reinforced
oh yeah but the people who stayed you
know the people who stayed most
everybody I've talked to is like yeah I
really like this season
yeah that's why first time sales well I
don't think that's the
reason I think just throwing it up there
so quickly not advertising it properly I
don't think it's a good time slot I
think Nick has this problem where it
does stick out like a sore thumb when
you've got like shows aimed at literally
a five year olds mindset and then you've
got you know avatar there yeah I mean
you know I suck it in every time every
time we watch like whatever the ending
of the show before it's clearly a tween
eight kids wearing the latest fashion
sitcom sort of Disney Channel I know and
if you know it's like that wrong with
that we were kids do that that that's
does by it's that when you have
something like Korra which is clearly
very much aimed towards like you know
Zev and martial arts and philosophy and
East Wing and I will say this to the
other thing is the original last
airbender then had kids in it yet still
you felt more like a kid show the thing
is if Nickelodeon wants to do this they
may have to actually come up with a
block of programming that's not aimed at
five-year-olds you know come up with a
series of shows and say okay this is
gonna be Nickelodeon's version of adults
well as you know that spongebob is
watched by many adults usually under a
certain substance but many adults I have
no problem with people watch fun so I
don't have anything against I really
don't your anti sponge I guess I don't
care no that's the funny thing when I
made that joke people just like you have
no idea spongebob
Don hell oh it used to be so good it
needs to die they need to kill it first
off I don't even know they were running
new episodes yeah that Mel's gonna show
second like I leave it still a second I
just was just like whoa I'm actually not
saying anything negative about spongebob
I was just cracking a joke because I'm
just like it was the only thing I could
think of off the top of my head I always
thought favorite reruns I didn't know
that yeah cuz that's why I that's what I
thought I thought they've been rerunning
them all these years didn't realize it
was but I have no problem with that and
if people like to watch SpongeBob's I
watched dumb cartoons no spongebob go
downhill I feel okay nothing that's a
bad shot
it is but go to mind something like hold
on a public Facebook region like there
were like 96 Commons and half of them
were dedicated to how spongebob just
doesn't work anymore and how great it
was back and it'll really be bad to make
spongebob squarepants code a pickle I'm
just telling you at the potion society
damn pace and tones that jumpin and are
don't sit here and send comment to me
like Rob tanks in fact I went downhill
or robbed like I am indifferent to
spongebob don't give a shit
oh here another but I'm just telling you
what people told me and I'm like wow I
didn't realize funds Bob had such
dislike you know used to be like water I
used to be about the Aqua life man the
water life but yeah they need to create
something
aimed towards a block like their version
of Adult Swim
yeah aimed at like 15 year-olds though
actually some of adults what I do think
is aimed at it depends on the show but
yeah something where you could get like
teenagers and young adults and you know
people our age to be like oh well maybe
I'm supposed to take this a little more
seriously and I don't feel weird turning
on the station there's every which way
or this shit writes itself or spongebob
squarepants or fucking Sanjay and Gregg
you know there is a Craig could Sanjay
and Craig I don't know it's the real
reporter captivates the weird one it's
the weird one with the snake all I know
is I watch like 1 minute of it and I
thought I dropped acid I'm like really
look I don't think I'm sorry Bob days
tour
you missed the ads with him to where the
snakes running around is like do
something cool and then like Ben
Franklin like farts in this race oh it's
great for my face - that cool I'm not
really this needs to be on before core
and this is what Cora lost so yeah hey
wait we probably ramble on long enough
so get good episode good fighting
good episode Nickelodeon good to see you
next one online so um yeah I mean yeah
nothing's been the same so spongebob
went downhill
2008 that was the air that was the peak
pineapple what the fuck